the rapid spread of the virus is
triggering urgent action around the
world so far at least 81 countries have
reported cases 95,000 people or more
have been infected worldwide and at
least 3,200 of them have died Charlie
d'Agata is in Rome where Italy's
government has closed all schools in the
country Charlie good morning to you they
are certainly not playing around in
Italy what else is going on there they
are not playing around Gayle and it's
not just the school's movie theaters are
shut
sporting events are now being held
behind closed doors tourist sites are
open but you can see for yourself the
numbers are way down now as this crisis
deepens is this is what is in store for
the United States that nationwide shut
down is Italy's most dramatic step yet
to stop dead the spread of a virus that
shows no sign of slowing down
new numbers here overnight have
skyrocketed more than 3,000 cases now a
hundred seven dead expanding regions in
lockdown all major soccer matches held
in empty stadiums you don't normally
supply this forget hand sanitizers and
masks at a Rome pharmacy we even found
goggles and hazmat suits for sale people
are scared people are worried yeah there
is a situation of the people are going
crazy crazy because the situation is not
explained so much to Iran were in just
over two weeks cases have soared to more
than 3,500 though there are fears the
outbreak is far greater
but Ayatollah Ali Khamenei has instead
accused other countries of hiding
figures in South Korea the outbreak has
forced a shortage of hospital beds in
the epicenter Daegu more than 5,700
cases making it the second highest in
the world behind China where the
outbreak began more than 80 thousand
cases 3,000 dead though the only country
where the spread of the illness has
slowed down so here the kids may be
looking forward to a couple of weeks off
but when they closed down schools in
Japan it caused chaos because hospital
staff had to stay home to look after
their kids go
Charlie d'Agata in Rome we thank you and
you need to be careful too thanks a lot
you